a new lawsuit by former Playboy model
Karen McDougal claims people close to
president Trump colluded with her lawyer
to keep her silent about an alleged 2006
affair that lasted ten months mcdougal
accepted a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars from American media incorporated
the parent company of several tabloid
publications she sold her story and in
return expected chances to write and
model ami says that Magoo McDougal quote
has been free to respond to press
enquiries about her relationship with
President Trump since 2016 so they say
the suggestion that ami silenced her is
completely without merit the White House
has said president Trump denies this
affair mr. Trump's personal lawyer
Michael Cohen did not answer our request
for comment peter stresses karen
MacDougall's current lawyer good morning
and I assume you're ready to talk you're
ready to answer all the questions I'm
ready so first tell us Peter what did
she think she was signing and why did
she sign it so American media Inc not
only owns the National Enquirer but they
also owned six major fitness magazines
including Men's Fitness and she was the
first woman on the cover of that
magazine in 1999 so she thought she was
signing a legitimate modelling and
writing contract now to be clear she
knew that they were buying her story and
she knew that the National Enquirer was
not going to publish it but she had no
idea that she wasn't going to be able to
respond to two press inquiries
now ami takes the position that she can
yes and we're thrilled you know she'll
be speaking tomorrow and finally being
able to set the record straight with
Anderson Cooper but the reality is
they're private position is very
different and for over a year they've
made her terrified
oh so after the New Yorker Ronan Farrow
story came out they said any further
disclosures will lead will breach the
contract and will lead to significant
monetary damages and we all know what
that means you get sued for twenty
million dollars so their public position
is very different than their private one
and she needs to get out of this of this
bogus contract but if they're saying she
can talk now then isn't everything taken
care of it's taken care of this week
while we're
the news but this is they have these
rights in perpetuity and so I really
want to be clear Karen doesn't want any
money we will settle this case tomorrow
if they give up their rights
she'll assign them to a non-profit a
legitimate nonprofit there's many ways
to structure it she doesn't want money
what does she want it more than just
tell her story and what else does she
want out of this contract but but why
because if she doesn't get out of this
contract they own her rights in
perpetuity at any point in the future
they can do what they've done for the
past year and there's nothing she can do
about it but they say they've allowed
her to write and participate in the
journalism that's a part of AMI
oh I'm talking about silencing her I'm
talking about this specific story about
anything having to do with her prior
relationship with Donald Trump at this
moment they're letting her tomorrow
speak but there's a lot of future
moments stormy Daniels attorney said
that his client had been physically
threatened has your client been
physically threatened absolutely not
there have been no physical threats
we've heard nothing of the sort
but what has happened is there's been a
coordinated campaign for over a year to
convince Karen that she would be sued or
her reputation would be besmirched if
she spoke her truth about this issue
that's what we're concerned about and
that's why we want to get out of this
country I'm trying to figure out what is
her truth was this wasn't this a
consensual relationship it was
consensual and it was an important
relationship to her I mean I don't want
to speak for her but you know she had a
relationship with him for 10 months did
she regret having an affair with a
married man
absolutely when was the last time she
spoke with the president I believe a few
years ago but again you know she's the
person to ask but I believe a few years
and you're her her current lawyer but
she alleges that her lawyer at the time
of the deal Keith Davidson was
coordinating with Michael Cohen and
colluding is there any evidence of that
oh there's something there's plenty of
evidence that in the first instance we
know he represented stormy Daniels and
another woman in direct hush deals
Karin had no idea that he was
representing them that those deals were
happening and then more recently the New
York Times has reported that in Karen's
deal itself the day it was signed he
emailed Michael Cohen and they got on
the phone and he said the deal is done
and that's remarkable because this deal
happened in one day she was close to
having a deal with ABC where she was for
no money going to go and tell her story
and and her lawyer brought her back to
ami and in a day said hey we got to get
this signed a contract that she didn't
understand and we have to note that
Keith Davidson issued a statement and
his spokesperson said he quote fulfilled
his obligations and zealously advocated
for miss mcdougal to accomplish her
stated goals at the time what is your
response to a statement my response is
that's a very interesting perspective I
think no one who's admitted to any bar
would share but you know he's certainly
entitled to his opinion why is it
important for your client to tell her
story then or now if not to just hurt
the president well let me be clear Karen
is a Republican she voted for the
president
she holds no ill will one of the one of
the reasons it's taken there I think so
long to come forward is that's actually
a concern that if ever there were a case
that was not motivated by naked politics
it's this one what she wants is to
correct the lies that a.m. I have has
told you know about her her motivations
her honesty she she she does not want
publicity you know Peter Peter how can
you say she doesn't want publicity you
know I'm not trying to be cute here but
she's she's suing she's saying I had an
affair with the president I want to tell
my story I'm trying to think what will
change after she tells her story and
then you say she doesn't want publicity
here's here's how I can say that you'll
the the proof is in the pudding what I'm
telling you is she's gonna do this
interview she's gonna tell her truth and
then you're not gonna see her again and
that's what someone does who doesn't
want publicity and you can hold me to it
because you know it's either true or
it's not I know it's true I'm confident
and I think people are gonna be very
interested to see her perspective
because the issue it's nuanced it's
complicated and it's important is she
willing to give back some of the
$150,000 oh if this if this contract is
voided she will give back the the money
she got she will make it clear that she
doesn't get profits from it she does not
want money she wants out from under the
thumb of this organization that has
effectively controlled her life for for
over a year that's what this is about
we'll be hearing from her tomorrow night
yeah Peter thank you so much for joining
us thank you